from the post-millennial
minnesota bank and trust moves to cancel
my pillow founders bank accounts the
accounts in question are lindell
management lindell outreach linda
recovery network lindell tv lindelof
foundation lindell publishing frank
speech michael lindell personal and my
store it's kind of crazy they've gone
after everything associated with this
guy the announcement came on on friday's
episode of war room where host and
former trump adviser steve ben played a
recording of a telephone call between a
top executive at minnesota bank and
trust and lindell's controller
the executive stated during the call
that the bank a subsidiary of heartland
financial had concerns about being
connected with someone who could be in
the news quote not that the fbi is even
sniffing and looking
but what if somebody came and said do
you know what we are going to subpoena
all of his account records and this and
that and then all of a sudden we make
the news so it's more of a reputation
risk
i'll just tell you this
minnesota bank and trust i would never
go anywhere near
if they if you're running a business and
your bank is shut down because they're
scared of bad pr
do not bank with these people
it's not just that you think it's just
as mike lindell is a big famous guy
cnn's gone after regular people over
memes so yeah if a bank is saying we
don't want to be involved with someone
in the news well we know these media
companies are willing to go after
regular people and little old ladies i
would not feel safe banking with that
company i don't believe the reputation
excuse at all especially when you when
you look at the history of big banks
especially institutions like hsbc and
their money laundering for drug cartels
knowingly doing so when you look at what
they did with jeffrey epstein especially
deutsche bank that literally had to
settle a fine of over a hundred and
fifty million dollars because they
ignored all of his red flags jeffrey
epstein was able to bank with jp morgan
and chase citibank deutsche bank he
never got de-banked who gets debanked uh
the my pillow guy and then people like
julian assange that was debanked in 2010
politically
when he was shut down by a swiss bank he
was shut down by paypal he of course
then went into bitcoin and then had a 50
000
increase of his money and is estimated
to have around 37 million dollars
because of that switch from bitcoin so
again this political debanking is
nothing new the big banks are of course
tied into big government the
intelligence agencies and i think this
is another lesson showing that yes they
all work together
in many extensive ways which is
absolutely troubling because it's
becoming more and more political by the
day i think this is a big red flag for
centralized banking in general you see
the amount of control that i think is
desired from this like
if you want to if you want to buck the
system and and all the money is
controlled by one person then then you
don't get to have any money anymore and
live in this world with no money that's
not how this world works i don't i don't
like privatized banking at all at this
point public banking yeah i would have a
couple thing to say about that one is
the
astonishing and really uh unfortunate
thing is there is
a certain case to the reputational
argument which is to say that in the
present regime
you're worse off reputationally being
michael lindell and associating yourself
with donald trump in various ways than
being somebody like jeffrey epstein um
they're just as a result of the peculiar
hierarchy of taboos that exists in the
regime and secondly i think it really
speaks his point that anyone in
liddell's position who you know speaks
out against the regime in various ways
de-banking is what the united states
government does to adversary governments
it is the domestic
recapitulation of economic sanctions and
so it needs to be understood i think
broadly in this context of the
government and its associated
institutions wielding its power
domestically against american citizens
for political purposes do you think that
the government told this bank to do this
or was this just a private bank well i
mean i think that this this is all part
of the same ecology so the fact that
banking institutions that major
platforms of the communication
infrastructure aren't technically part
of the government they are part of the
regime and that's what's more relevant
and it's simply if you reach the level
of michael lindell if you are a
dissident on that level you jeopardize
your capacity to exist in any normal way
and having financial freedom and being
able to bank as part of that and so
basically lindell's position is similar
to the position of say the government of
iran for instance that i mean that's how
i would interpret it and functionally
it's the same it's just in lindell's
case he's an american citizen and in
iran's case it is a foreign adversary or
at least allegedly announced yeah the
the public banking thing i don't know if
i'm a fan of yeah after i said it i was
like
not only public i do like the options uh
like non-profit banking um credit unions
non-profit banking imagine a bank that
wasn't trying to profit well that's
basically a credit union yeah thank you
so they so for me my credit union it's
like no atm fees i get international
free atm transactions which is crazy
because when i was traveling around for
advice and stuff that was amazing it was
amazing
and uh the the credit union industry was
able to they're able to absorb a lot of
losses because they're not in it for a
profit so during all the occupy stuff
they gained billions of dollars people
were switching over i think that's one
big move you can make but there's still
the problem of a credit union still
being a private institution who can ban
you and so i think what we're seeing
from here is the is the power of
cultural enforcement over uh say legal
enforcement
you don't need to make something illegal
you don't need to violate someone's
rights to still violate their rights you
know what i mean like joe biden doesn't
need to go to this bank and say get rid
of this guy he's in my way they need
only put enough pressure they need a
reporter will call them up and say why
are you doing this i broke this story it
was a few years ago i think it was
actually four years ago
the uh it was enrique tario he got
banned from chase because a quote
unquote journalist
sent an email basically threatening the
bank saying why are you providing
financial services to white supremacists
and the bank internally just said
terminate we don't have anything to do
with this
i understand why the bank freaks out
journalists do this stuff as an attack
and they know they're doing it the way
they ask the question right for what
business for what public good do we need
to understand why a bank provides
banking services to a person of a
certain political persuasion we don't
everybody has a bank because people have
banks so a journalist who contacts a
bank and asks those questions knows what
they're doing and why they're doing it
that's interesting the way you said
everybody has a bank and uses a bank
because that's kind of what we believe
what we're brainwashed to believe
growing up but like you're saying darren
the government can just sanction anybody
at any time anything and that's an a
common tool that it uses in the war
against its adversaries is shut off the
bank it's their favorite tool if you
look at the way that the americans have
been kind of pushing their will on the
world economic sanctions economic
warfare are their main ways of of
achieving a lot of their objectives they
go to a country and they say hey we're
going to take away your ability to even
have money in the world if you don't
implement this policy and this is what
the united states does this is nothing
even compared to the world bank and the
imf and if you look at what uh you know
the the stories of the economic hitman
if you look at what really happens
behind the scenes with a lot of these
banks and powerful people all around the
world it is absolutely corrupt and
sinister to see the corruption that
really is happening that we don't even
know about right it's the analog so what
happens to lindell and there are various
other cases he's not uh he's not the
first as you point out um it is the
analog to you know
using the leverage of the swift system
to cut out you know uh
foreign adversaries or to use that
leverage to pressure them to do
something we want it's it's an extension
of the same basic principle and done for
for the same reasons do you have
any information on the swift banking
system maybe a brief overview i know a
little bit about it i believe that it
kind of oversees visa and mastercard
right it's i mean it's just you know the
united states government essentially
controls it it's essential for any kind
of transactions that go through
particularly in in dollars and
um it's a major part of being able to
participate in the global economy and
particularly in the past five years or
so
the united states has really leaned on
economic sanctions because there's no
appetite for war since iraq there's just
no public appetite for war and so it's
sort of the middle ground that they can
use to really be severe but not send
troops into a place and so they've
leaned on these sanctions and the cost
is it really puts pressure on the u.s
dollar there's only so much
pressure the dollar can take having to
sustain the united states foreign policy
objectives before before it the pillars
collapse but they've been leaning on it
very hard and
the result is russia and china have been
talking and you know cooperating and
thinking about developing alternatives
to swift system and so forth so
ultimately it might be counterproductive
but
we love to sanction people economically
overseas and that's what you see more
domestically because the domestic
political adversaries like michael and
dell are considered enemies in just the
same way that the u.s government
considers iran an enemy i remember uh
man 12 13 maybe even maybe it was even
like 14 years ago you know alex jones is
talking about
one one world currency global currency
there
all these people on the internet were
talking about the amero that there was
going to be a canadian mexican american
currency and that always confused me
because i was like can't you just use
your credit card any country you go to
and so within only a few years i'm
traveling around the world working for
vice and i've got a i got a visa card
and i go to all these countries and
swipe it with no questions asked i walk
in i'd say you know let me get the the
schnitzel when i'm in you know israel
whatever and then swipe no questions
asked no problem just right there and
then i started telling my friends when i
would hear people say like yeah one of
these days they're gonna have a one
world currency and i was like bro it's
called visa and mastercard you can go to
any one of these countries just use it
right it's here it's happened already
wait till you learn about bitcoin tim
and i've been telling people bitcoin is
the perfect global store of value
decentralized instant trackable
and when they've got ai
that is tracking all of the transactions
they know who you are where you are what
you're doing and you don't even realize
people are like i can use bitcoin to buy
things you're not supposed to buy it's
like dude they know who you are that's
if you let people know your address so
if no one knows your address
still well there's different ways of
finding out amazon and jeff bezos are
working on a lot of different
technological advancements that would
kind of break bitcoin and that and and
make sure they could track trace and
database everything so there are
exceptions to the world i would say at
this point bitcoin itself
is is is broken in that capacity it's
not private a lot of you know and caps
libertarians thought it really was but
they don't need to know your address
to see the transactions made and then
have an ai just calculate it was you
based on the things you post on social
media based on the phone you use your
mac address they can easily track this
stuff they're working on that technology
i haven't heard of them developing it or
using it yet to be honest let's be real
are they going to publicly disclose they
can do it already
no but it's not that hard to calculate
if facebook is already if you're getting
so i'll tell you something funny i
ordered these little cards they're
really really cool it's a it's a black
card you it's got a joint in the middle
and on the sides and you flip it and it
forms this like kite shape and then you
can pull the sides up and it's got two
little holes where you can put your
phone and use it as a tripod it's so
awesome it like flips around you can
manipulate it and you can take your
phone set it up so you can you know
record yourself with your phone or
record people with your phone the funny
thing is i posted a video to my
instagram of me playing my guitar and i
was trying to set my phone up and i'm
like it's so annoying like how to get
your phone to stand up and then within
an hour i didn't i never said anything
to anybody about this i didn't go gee i
sure need a tripod or some kind of stand
for my phone i get an advertisement on
instagram being like buy this to set
your phone up and i was like that's
really weird it's and it's not because
they're reading your mind or listening
to you i never said any words about this
it's because there are algorithms that
just know based on your behaviors
there's the famous story of the the guy
there's this father he gets
maternity
advertisements in the mail for his
daughter and he's like why are they
sending my daughter maternity stuff so
he complains and they were like oh sir
it's because our computer identified
your daughter's pregnant that's it and
he was like how the things she was
looking at and it wasn't this is the
crazy thing she wasn't looking up
diapers she wasn't looking up anything
she didn't know she was pregnant the
algorithm knew that when women start
looking up certain items certain foods
before they even realize that the
computers know they're pregnant and sent
the information to her dad because she
still lived with them that's so i'm
telling you man with bitcoin if you
think they don't know who you are what
you're doing you are wrong it's all
public but but there's zcash there's
monero there are those are a lot better
they get banned they have been in the
past been getting banned from um trading
networks unfortunately yep monero in
particular and that's the thing is once
you reached a level like monero and
you're actually a threat it becomes a
national security issue and so they try
in the periphery they'll ban it from all
the major exchanges it's particularly
hard to get if you're in the u.s
um
and then if it persists then it becomes
you know a a mechanism for terrorism
financing and they'll go after it more
aggressively or they'll just say
so that's the that's the ultimate
bottleneck is once something becomes a
national security threat
um all bets are off thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you